the full title of this song you're about  to hear by Dave Matt is samurai cop oh  joy begin I'm gonna be quiet and I will  evaluate this naked or afraid  screams and curses you for days  oh joy begin sweet thing oh joy begin  [Music]  let's not forget these early days we we  can say we lose our way  fear and pain oh joy be in first just  one step  [Music]  with  laughter see  [Music]  [Applause]  first just one stem  let's not forget these  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  same  lose our way  fear  oh joy  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  ear nose and kiss like my first and  swells Oh  for easily  [Music]  again  the same  who's our way  [Music]  oh joy bacon  beautiful robin's all turned on oh it's  great when guys play the guitar and sing  right Robin I mean from a sexual space  nothing